ce débat il traverse la droite depuis
plus de 20 ans en 1991 dans une
interview choc valéry giscard d'estaing
évoque je cite
l'immigration-invasion
ce que les français souhaitent pour eux
c'est le droit du sang lorsque un enfant
né en france de parents étrangers il
devient il devient français moi je dis
je préfère qu'on devienne français on
dit en ayant demandé la nationalité
je suis très attaché à la notion de
droit du sol pour une raison que je vous
expliquais c'est que je n'aime pas
l'idée du droit du sang qu'est ce que ça
veut dire le droit du sang vous savez
bien ce qu'ils en ont fait un certain
nombre c'est la pureté on ne devient
français par le sang que ça veut dire la
pureté du sang la france n'est pas un
pays d'immigration et nous devons nous
donner les moyens réglementaires et
administratifs de gérer un quota zéro
des migrants il est des quartiers
où je peux comprendre l'exaspération de
certains de nos compatriotes pères ou
mères de famille rentrant du travail de
soir apprenant que leur fils s'est fait
arracher son camp au chocolat à la
sortie du collège par des voyous qui lui
explique qu on mange pas pendant le
ramadan si vous ajoutez à cela
le bruit et l'odeur
est bien le travailleur français sur le
palier devient fou moi je suis pour une
vision de la société française qui
respecte d'abord notre diversité je suis
heureux d'ailleurs de voir que les
évêques de france vient d'écrire une
lettre qui dit exactement la même chose
nous sommes direct nous n'avons pas les
mêmes religions par la même couleur de
peau par la même origine il faut
respecter cette diversité qui fait notre
richesse
le racisme anti blanc seing existe je le
vis moi sur mon territoire aux convois
entre la haute loire et la loire
proximité de saint-etienne ce n'est pas
en nous alignant si peu que ce soit sur
les positions et sur les thèses du front
national que nous diffuserons les
électeurs de voter pour cette formation
politique
alors question pas facile pour qui veut
rassembler sa famille de quelles paroles
vous sentez vous la plus proche
ce que je crois c'est qu'une immigration
incontrôlée avec une intégration ratée
ça peut disloquer la nation est ce que
je crois aussi c'est que on est face à
ce défi aujourd'hui ce défi est réel ce
défi existe et ça va être le défi du
prochain quinquennat refaire nations
avec des français qui se regarde qui
vivent côte à côte et qui ne doivent pas
se retrouver face à face alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire mais ça veut dire
reprendre le contrôle des flux
migratoires et des entrées sur le
territoire on a aujourd'hui deux cent
soixante douze mille titres de séjour
qui sont donnés chaque année c'est
évidemment trop c'est ce que je pense
nous avons des détournements du droit
d'asile colossaux avec cent mille
demandeurs d'asile dont la majorité sera
déboutée mais restera en france et
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible ça
n'est pas souhaitable c'est pour ça que
moi je souhaite une loi
constitutionnelle avec des quotas
migratoires et ses quotas selon un
principe très simple les pays d'origine
qu'ils ne reprennent pas leurs
clandestins n'auront plus droit aux
visas je vois d'ailleurs que le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui avait été totalement
immobile et impuissant sur ce sujet a
commencé à
j'ai aimé il agite un sabre de bois
puisque les visas qui l'a bloqué sont
des visas de court séjour et ses visas
de court séjour eh bien ils peuvent être
données dans n'importe quel pays de
l'union européenne donc l'interdiction
de visa des manuels macron est
aujourd'hui contourner voilà donc je
note que vous n'avez voulu citer
personne dans la galerie de portraits de
déclaration que quand on vous a proposé
mais parce que c'est moi la candidate
valley et c'est ma ligne qui sera
proposé aux français c'est celle que je
porte et la phrase de bernard stasi
prononcé il ya trente ans n'est pas en
s'alignant sur les thèses de l'extrême
droite que nous dissuaderont ses
électeurs et ce qu'elle vous parle
aujourd'hui d'abord on n'est pas du tout
sûr les mêmes thèses nous on est pour
des solutions qui vont fonctionner
l'immigration zéro ça n'existe pas ça ne
marchera pas il faut une immigration de
travail il faut aussi une immigration
étudiante il faut limiter l'immigration
familiale dans la mesure où nous voulons
des personnes qui parlent le français
qui passent un examen de français qui
est des ressources suffisantes pour
s'intégrer et qui respecte les valeurs
de la république mais aujourd'hui nous
avons des solutions pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'immigration et c'est pas
en niant le problème c'est pas en
faisant comme s'il n'existait pas que
nous reconquerrons la confiance des
français
[Musique]